well good afternoon everyone um we're
really pleased to have uh the the the
next one of our Deans invited lecture
series here um today we have Brighton
Saha from Amazon
AWS um this series really is intended to
emphasize the opportunities for
connections between the School of
Engineering and Yale and Industry and
our conversations today with Bron have
really uh driven home that point we've
been jumping from topic to topic uh all
kinds of different ways that what's
going on at the University uh
interrelates and can impact what's going
on at Amazon and certainly vice versa um
part of the infrastructure that brenon
has been responsible for developing an
Amazon is really the backbone that will
power the
transformative tools uh that we're
witnessing in Industry right now with
generative AI um this is a massively
computationally Rich area but also a
massively computationally expensive and
data driven area so um what I hope we'll
learn today is sort of ways that he sees
a future interaction between Yale and
Amazon U being productive and profitable
um for all of us so with that I would
love to welcome so I will say Bretton
was I think Jang Sha's first PhD student
is that correct so Jang was the uh chair
of computer science certainly you know
the whole time I've been here until this
year um and uh it's really wonderful to
see uh these you know birds that have
taken flight come back home to to roost
share share their experiences with us so
he's going to give a an introduction and
tell us a little bit about his
trajectory and then he and I will have a
brief chat and then you guys can ask him
some questions okay so with that take it
away thank thank you D thank
you it's nice to be back home uh you
know I spent a lot of time lot of days
and nights at the AK Watson in the zoo
and other places and it was really nice
to see how the
university has uh evolved over the last
many years thanks to leadership from you
know Dean Brock the year leadership
Jeong
himself and seeing the amount of
Investments that are being made in
computer science and engineering so what
I want to talk talk about today is some
ways in which we have been using
generative Ai and enabling customers in
the Enterprise to use generative AI
today most of the machine learning vast
majority of machine learning and AI in
the world happens on AWS happens on the
infrastructure that mid builds and what
I wanted to talk about and where I'm
hoping you can get um some insights on
is where the industry is going um and
and what would be the research problems
that would be interesting especially
from an industry perspective where the
science is uh in terms of where we can
take it out to customers and where the
science isn't in terms of where I think
there's a lot of fundamental research to
be done in a university like y so let me
get started
um so there really have been you know a
set of tipping points around generative
AI um one of them has been just
astonishing increase in the amount of
compute capability if you think about it
if you think about computer signs it was
driven by Mo's law and Mo's law said
that the amount of compute is going to
double every 18 months what we have seen
in Ai and machine learning for the last
10 years is that compute capacity has
been doubling every 3 and 1 half months
we are going at six times literally six
times the speed of M law we're going
literally at six times the speed at
which it used to go and it evolved
really really fast even if you look at
the last 5 years that's about 30 years
of progress in it land and now you go
back 30 years there was no Amazon no
Google no Facebook no meta no Twitter
and so on so this field is moving
extremely fast the other thing that has
happened is the emergence of of Internet
scale data and I'll give you a little
bit of insight into what that is doing
uh with large language models and then
the third thing that has happened is the
amount of machine learning Innovation
and on the next slide I'm going to talk
to you about this but the other thing
that has also happened that I think is
really interesting for Yale as a
university for students and faculty here
is the role of the cloud because what we
have done is we have made it possible to
make this compute and this data readily
available to anybody that wants to use
it at a very very cheap cost so what has
this meant for
Innovation if you think about machine
learning the capacity of machine
learning models and you know you can
measured it by the number of
parameters just in the last 3 years has
grown by 1,600
x this is super super super
exponential okay and that is is driving
amazing Innovations now what does that
mean from a data perspective if you
think about we
humans in the course of a
lifetime an average human will probably
listen to about a billion words or two
billion
words when we train these Foundation
models we train them on trillions of
words so each one of these Foundation
models is being trained thousands time
thousands of times of data that an
average human will be consuming in the
lifetime you know if you if I give you
another perspective on this all of
Wikipedia is about 18 gab 18 to 20
Gigabytes when we train these models we
train them on trillions on terabytes of
data and that means that you're putting
in the knowledge of thousands of
wikipedias into one of these models and
that is what is triggering this amazing
Innovation that is coming on in
generative AI now there's a lot of
there's a lot of research to be done in
terms of making it really Deployable at
scale in the industry and some of that
is what I'm going to talk
about so this Innovation can transform
Industries it will transform Industries
and I'll give you a little bit of sense
of some of the places where we are doing
this
so let me start with um Amazon code
Whisperer this is a software development
tool that is based on generative AI okay
we have seen a lot of companies now
start using this tool so let me actually
show you how this works so all you are
doing is as a programmer you are just
writing comments you're just putting in
English language text so the programmer
came in and said you know just light me
a write me a program to upload a file
from S3 okay using server side
encryption then code
Whisperer is actually it takes this
command and then code Whisperer is just
going to come in and generate this file
by
itself this is all automatically
generated as a program
you just have to write this English
stuff okay and then code Whisperer will
give you a few um hints about it and
then you come in and this is another
Java thing and all you're doing is you
know you're writing this it went too
fast it said create some stuff and code
Whisperer is going to basically create
the entire function for you okay and
what we have
seen
so you know this is what the programmer
writes create a function to do
this and it'll generate the entire
function for
you okay and then you can go in and run
some checks and so on and so forth so
what does that mean what does this mean
for um the software development industry
and what does it mean for
um
what does it mean for a university like
Yale we have
studies that show people that are using
Code Whisperer like
tools are about 50% more productive than
people who don't because you're not
doing your own
coding but there's something more
profound going on and these tools by the
way are going to keep getting better
every year so imagine 5 years from now
when these tools are really
good what is going on is something very
profound here it's that Java and Python
and rust are no longer the programming
languages English is the new programming
language and you can imagine that we are
going to be able to do this with say
Italian or Chinese or Hindi or
something and so our mother
tongues become the new programming
language what does this mean for Yale
how sure Computer Science teaching
evolve to address
this you I was talking in fact this
morning with Dean Brock about how do you
bring more liberal arts education to
stem to computer science and engineering
but this may basically mean that anyone
who is an English major or history major
whatever is now going to become a
software developer 5 years 10 years from
now and so when you have democratized
this to some
extent what does it mean for innovation
in the world when every person is a
software
developer and these are I think things
that you know University like Yale
should think about because it's really
kind of a university that's at the
Forefront of how does technology impact
Society 5 to 10 years from now and how
do we educate people in that
way the next one um I'll talk
about is what's happening in medicine so
there is a lot of work we are doing in
my team and elsewhere in terms of
applying AI to medicine and the reason
that is happening is you can see just
like with Mo's law the cost of
sequencing and this the cost of
sequencing a human genome is dropping in
a very fundamental way it used to be a
huge amount you know few million
hundreds of millions 20 years back to
now it's about $200
and because this cost has dropped so
dramatically you can now spur an entire
industry that's based on this in fact so
we have this um challenges you know in
terms of being able to do genomic
sequencing and as a result of
that um I was actually talking to some
yesterday um yesterday at dinner who is
at Columbia University and they were
actually talking about hey we also want
and I'm sure the same thing is true here
in the school of medicine or even in you
know in the engineering departments that
are trying to do some AI in medicine
that you have a lot of infrastructure
issues you have to deal with if you want
to do that kind of genomic sequencing
okay is why we I
would you know we came out with this
service that is actually being used by a
lot of universities and Public Health
Department departments now to be able to
do uh Gene sequencing and precision
medicine and in fact you know the uh the
Department of Public Health in Chicago
they were able to use these tools to run
some analysis and they found that when
you go like 10 miles from downtown
Chicago your life expectancy Falls by
like 8 or 10 or 12 years and the reason
that happens is because of difference in
access to specific kinds of care and
they were able to do that because
they're able to use these tools to see
what kind of Medical Care isn't being
afforded there and they have now changed
the way that Medical Care is being given
you know similarly genomics England you
know they have a huge database
of probably the world's largest of
humans who have genetic mutations uh
with some rare diseases and they're now
using these tools to do a lot of
precision medicine and I do think that
medicine is a domain that is Rip for a
lot of innovation from computer science
from Ai and a lot of other
fields I'll give you another example of
the kind of innovation that we can do
about so patients
today are walking with tons of data you
know you have all of your um variables
and you know you're getting all kinds of
data from
um multiple different data
sources but the thing is 97% of this
data is not being analyzed is not being
used and so imagine the quality of
patient outcomes that we could improve
if there was a way for us to be able to
analyze this
data okay and this being able to analyze
this data I think is another really
interesting research that I think a
university like y would be perfectly
suited for because you have a school of
medicine that's a leader you have the
engineering parts that's a leader you
have the data science parts that's a
leader and so this kind of
interdisciplinary work would just be
amazing in terms of improving patient
outcomes now there's one way in which we
are doing this which is clinical
documentation so today when you go to a
physician um because of electronic
health records that interaction that
you're having with the physician needs
to be scribed and so the Physicians are
actually doing it and then then creating
a summary and then they're uploading it
to your electronic health records it
turns out physicians in the US on
average spend about 40% of the time
doing this scribing and that is the time
that is not being spent on patient care
that's the time that is really an
unproductive use of the physician's time
and so what we have done and we have
launched this product a little bit is
using generative AI
to automatically generate these patient
physician uh summaries so as you're
talking to a physic that particular
conversation is getting captured it's
automatically getting transcribed a
generative AI model is automatically
generating the summary now the key
Innovation that we did here that I think
is very relevant also from a research
point of view is as you know generative
AI can also have hallucination so you
need to have a very high degree of
accuracy and so one of the things that
we did here which I think was a pretty
nice piece of innovation but there's a
lot more research to be done is What's
called the concept of grounding so we
have the original transcript we create a
summary but every part of that summary
we put a link to the original source
that says here is why I created the
summary okay and that is what helps make
this um Deployable to
Enterprises there is
supposed to
reduce the scribing time by
70% and we are partnering with 3m who
have 300,000 Physicians across the US
now imagine reducing the time or making
them more productive by 70% for 300,000
physicians in the US in fact I was
looking at all of the places that this
will go into POC and I was really glad
to know that El new heaven hospital is
actually one of them okay and the reason
I go into this example is to say that
you may be looking at a lot of
generative AI some of it may seem to be
hype but a lot of it is actually being
put into real production at scale
deployment and so all of the research
that you can do in terms of making it
accurate in terms of reducing
hallucinations in terms of finding ways
to do the grounding actually helps in
these
situations
so here is how it actually works I
already talked about this so you know
the patient
says um this one is not showing you can
see the highlighted Parts the patient
says you know this is what is going on
and we take the whole summary and then
we create it and you're not seeing it
here but we'll actually have links we'll
actually have references from here that
says this part came from here this part
came from
here okay and all of this is being
automatically generated
so what do you
need to do generative AI in the
Enterprise the first one is you really
want to have an easy way of building
with Foundation models and you want to
have a choice of building with
Foundation models and the second is then
infrastructure and that in both of these
there's a lot of research to be done
especially in the second one and I'll
talk a little bit on that so the first
one
was the kind of uh models that you can
use you know because use Bedrock there's
a bunch of other stuff to use and I
think the key thing that comes out from
a research perspective is that it's very
likely that one model isn't going to
rule them all and so there is a need for
figuring out what kinds of models work
well in what situations and and the
thing that I think will really
distinguish going forward is not just
the models but the data that is being
used to train them and in fact that's
where you know speak to Dean Brock which
is can Yale play a role given the amount
of data you have across the university
not just in the engineering and in the
social sciences in all of the libraries
in all of this is there a role that Yale
can play in making that data available
as training data because that would be
huge and would that that would not just
be huge from a research perspective in
moving Frontiers but I think that would
be a huge source of monetization as well
if Yale could figure out how to do that
so the first thing in here is um the set
of models and you know we have some of
the most state-of-the-art models that
you can play
with uh and then there are a lot more
models that are available on Sage maker
jump start now Foundation models can do
a lot of natural language interaction
with
you but Foundation models cannot execute
tasks yet on your behalf so for example
let's say you said you know give me all
of the options for having a plain ride
to Florida over
Thanksgiving you know today they are
probably going to give you all of those
options but then you would say and by
the way go make the bookings for me so
that action part is still not there and
that is why we actually augmented
bedrock with what we call agents where
agents can take actions on your behalf
now there's a lot of research going on
how do you make it safe how do you make
it secure um so you know it works in a
particular constraint set of uh
environments constraint set of actions
and so there's a lot of research to be
done here but you can clearly see that
is where the world is headed you can
clear clearly see that you're going to
be having some kind of a personal
assistant and say hey um I need these to
be bought go get this from the web and
so this notion of having actions and
assistance all of this is coming and so
there's a lot of really interesting
research to be done in terms of how do
you secure it how do you ensure privacy
of the data how do you ensure that the
actions being taken are uh well- meaning
and so on and so forth
okay next let me start a little bit
around uh the infrastructure most of
this is on
gpus um and of course we have our own Uh
custom silicon as well that's purpose
built
for that's purpose built for
[Music]
um for uh generative Ai and there's just
a ton of work to be done there's a ton
of systems research to be done in making
this more efficient even now customers
spend a lot of even now there's a lot of
investment to be done in training these
models and at every layer at the
hardware layer at the system software
layer at the tooling layer there's a ton
of innovation to be done in terms of
figuring out how we make this a lot more
efficient and you know we have some
ideas but if people are looking for
interesting research ideas this is where
um there's a lot of work to be done and
then there is
tooling what happens and again there's a
lot of HPC related stuff that you can do
here the thing that's different about
generative AI especially is the scale of
compute and so as you're training let's
say these Foundation models you're
probably training them on thousands of
gpus or other accelerators maybe for
months at end and so what you didn't
used to happen before was what about the
resiliency of the accelerator what if
one of the accelerators for some reason
has an error how do you recover from it
because you don't want to waste months
of work and so that is where things like
selfhealing systems that we have but you
know you can obviously do more there and
other kinds of optimizations become
really important and so for those of you
working on kind of the system software
side this is really fertile territory
for the kind of innovations that you can
do in terms of having real impact
the other thing that's happening is the
emergence of no code tools there's you
know no code software and this is all
about democratizing and making software
development accessible to a lot more
people so there's no code software tools
and then there's no code machine
learning tools and you know I mentioned
before that generative AI is going to
democratize software development like
English will be the new programming
language these nood tools are also about
how do I do point and click to get my
job done okay and this is yet another
Trend um when you think about product
development having these Aesthetics
Aesthetics right how do you make
something really simple to use how do
you make something really easy to use is
not just about Science Education it also
needs a lot of you know broad liberal
Arts kind of an education so you really
understand from a product you can think
about a product not just from the
engineering point of view but also from
the usability point of view how will
users interact with it and I think that
is one of the things again that a
university like Yale with its Rich
liberal arts tradition can do a really
good job of how do you train Engineers
who not only know how to build a product
but who can actually build a product
that's delightful to use and delightful
to use for a lot of other people when
you're talking about how do I develop a
software tool that's someone who doesn't
know anything about software uses it
okay and there's a lot of work that has
to go into designing that
stuff so this is going to be another
Trend um that is
important the reason I I wanted to talk
about Amazon monitron um is to show how
there can be synergies with what is
already a available and how Yale can
play into that uh because you know there
are some strengths we bring at AWS but
there are some strengths where we are
just not in the domain that Yale can
bring so what monitron does is it red it
uses machine learning for doing
predictive maintenance of your machines
like it predicts when your machine may
go down okay and the way it does that is
we have these sensors and these sensors
are monitoring your equipment for
temperature and vibrations okay and so
if you think of a machine when the
machine is about to break it kind of
sounds a little weird or it vibrates a
little weird it can get heated up and so
on and so forth so these sensors are put
on devices put on machines and then they
monitor the temperature and vibrations
of these
devices and then what we
use is you'll see see these in these
kinds of
things these machines are installed
these sensors are installed in these
kinds of machines and then they're
streaming it to the
cloud and in the cloud we detect
anomalies and based on those anomalies
we predict when something is going to
break and so there are a lot of
companies this is backer uh but you know
backer SKF and a bunch of other
companies Coke um that are actually
using using these for predicting when
their equipment will fail now here's
something interesting I was actually
talking about this as I mentioned I was
talking to some people from the Yale
School of Medicine yesterday and they
said well do you have anomaly detection
that we could use to predict
Strokes now you can
imagine this these sensors are actually
sending data to the cloud that is a Time
series dat data where we are predicting
anomalies now you can use those
predicting anomalies in our case to
detect when a machine is going to break
but you can imagine you can do this for
other kinds of Time series data as well
one of which could be Health Data now
where does where could AWS and Yale play
really well with each other if you have
to do this re if you have to do this
work and if you have to do this research
you need an infrastructure that will be
able to take data from millions and
billions milons of people be scalable be
robust and efficient and not and do all
of that animaly detection we have that
infrastructure here what someone else
could do is say look here is the domain
expertise here is what the data looks
like in a normal person here is where
the anomalies come in when someone is
going to fall sick so you could then
marry that domain expertise with our
infrastructure and then together we
could build some really interesting
things
and by the way I was talking to people
and this is probably applicable even to
the School of Engineering is you could
do we have similar things for image
processing so you can imagine that you
could have Radiology images being
uploaded and detect animales now there's
two aspects to that you have to build
infrastructure which we have and then
someone has to do the research that sits
on top and then together you end up with
some remarkable
systems
the other thing that you know is coming
across a lot is uh sustainable Mobility
so if you look at the automotive
industry that's really thinking about
electrification about uh you know
getting greener using batteries and so
one of the things that's happening now a
lot is using geospatial data uh to
figure out driving habits and optimizing
things so BMW has been working with us
you know and they do things like
predicting the impact of traffic where
do you put charging stations and a lot
of other stuff so you know all kinds of
data analysis going on but this is yet
another modality to the data which is
geospatial and how do I use it for
predicting user
behavior and so you know they're
basically looking at this for predicting
affinity for electric vehicles you know
depending on uh driving Tendencies and
where people do the drivings
okay um this I talked about all of the
applications you know first about the
rapid rate at which science is going
then about all of the applications then
where there are still research problems
in doing that and then the fourth this
one is yet another place where there's a
lot of research to be done but a lot of
interdisciplinary research to be done
which again knowing the heritage of Yale
is a great place for Yale to be in
because you know AI is going to you know
the spending on AI is going to just go
astronomical I mean you can look at all
kinds of um estimates those estimates
are always hundreds of billions or
trillions so it's going to be a pretty
large industry but there's also a need
to be able to use it responsibly to be
able to put in the right amount of guard
rails in it and that is what is not just
a computer science problem that's a
computer science with public policy with
you know there are legal implications of
it and so that is a holistic thing and I
think that is where again you know
universities can play a big role
especially in bringing interdisciplinary
work there's just a ton of research that
can be done here um in terms of this is
the core computer science part of it in
terms of fairness you know bias
detection toxicity and so on in terms of
explainability why is the model behaving
the way it is behaving in terms of
robustness you know how do you make it
safer from all kinds of injection
attacks and so on and so forth in terms
of privacy governance and so on so
especially with generative AI especially
with large language models there's a lot
of work to be done in this but there's
also a lot of work uh so you know we do
this and if you want to get a sense of
what is respons what is useful to
Industry take a look at the some of the
service cards because they talk about
how customers approach this problem and
how customers would like to get insights
into these
problems but it's just not there because
you know there's a lot of work on
Regulatory Agencies now there's a
regulation called ISO
4201 that is you know making its way
through in terms of how you regulate uh
or how you uh work on AI ML and that's
all great place for a lot of
interdisciplinary work to be done that's
going to have a huge impact on how we
deal with um AI ml finally I want to uh
talk about a couple of things that we do
uh in my team we also run the Amazon
research Awards um and you know we have
awarded over $35 million in support of
research um
and in the
last what 8 years we have funded more
than 220 universities in about 40
countries so you know it's a pretty
Global spread is actually uh funding
that we also do to Yale so I know that
um at this point we have actually
two two uh grants going on
one uh you know one with I think in the
genomics department and the lower one is
probably in the computer science
department um but you know this is
happens every year so if people have
good ideas submit to
these and in addition because this is
getting so interesting they're all
investing $100 million in helping
customers take generative AI projects
from Concepts to production and so these
are all really good areas to be focusing
on on in terms of your projects in terms
of your research in terms of enabling
things so that's all I have um and then
you know happy to take questions but
really the the the the key areas I would
talk about is foundation models and you
know there will be a multiplicity of
models there's some research to be done
there um the infrastructure so we can
actually reduce the cost by orders of
magnitude make it much more accessible
the kind of applications you know I
talked about Healthcare I talked about
software development but contact centers
industrial
manufacturing uh document processing you
know all of these are going to get um
Innovations and then finally Education
and Training um there's actually a
really interesting work that showed this
was done by BCG so we did a work with
Accenture that showed you know if you
use generative AI you become up to 50%
more productive BCG did similar work
they actually got similar results in
terms of productivity but one of the
interesting uh insights that came out of
their research was that for beginners
the jump in productivity was much higher
okay and so think of it as if you are a
new software engineer going to a company
you take a long time in fact you know I
was talking to Dean Brock about these
like you know we have this Amazon
universities and all that which which is
we are trying to get people up familiar
with the infrastructure we have and
that's a long ramp up process imagine if
things are getting automated that
becomes much easier so it become it's
actually a great leveler in terms of how
you upscale employees now if generative
AI is a great new tool for upscaling
employees ultimately a University's job
is to upskill society and so I think
it's it's really important for
universities especially eminent
universities like Yale to think about
what
would upskilling Society upskilling
students 10 to 15 years from now look
like okay and the question and the
thought that I would leave you with is
if Yale were founded today how would it
be run how would all of these technology
be integrated into how you
operate okay that's all I
have okay thanks thanks so much
president okay we can uh I
think
so I think a question to this last point
that I would love to know is if you so
let's say we were designing this new
version of Yale
and one of the first things we wanted to
do was to teach kind of a flagship
course called generative AI for I don't
know for undergraduates for non- Majors
or something like that what what would
be the elements you would
include and how would you bring this
kind of larger population into this
sphere of I what I think people are a
little worried about may be kind of seen
as exclusive in some way how do how do
we bring everybody in I think I would
look at it from two aspects one is a lot
of content creation will be assisted by
generative AI right and so let's say I
am an
artist um or I am someone that is
writing drafts the first draft a few
years from now will probably be created
by a generative AI assistant that then
you improve so the generative AI doesn't
take take away the role of the human
generative AI at least till now doesn't
have the creativity that a human has but
what it can get to is it can actually
accelerate your work and so previously
let's say you would have to create a
draft and you're thinking a long time
and you're writing it and you know
you're spending weeks over it it can
probably accelerate it to a couple of
hours and so that notion
of and that applies as much to the
non-engineering parts of a des a lot of
creative uh output happening there and
so the things that I would look at is
how do you use it as an assistant in a
daily
work how do you try to maybe automate
some of the tedious work that you do and
how do you make sure that people outside
of engineering outside of computer
science are aware of these tools and are
thinking about how to integrate that
into the daily lives
right the way I look at it almost is
this is like the emergence of the
internet and today everybody outside of
Cs and Engineering uses email like you
know email has become a natural way of
doing work you know messaging and all
this has become a natural way of doing
work um and so how do you integrate
these Technologies into your way of
working the difference with previous
Technologies the difference with prior
technical
changes is that prior technical changes
were not a creative assistant right this
is the thing that can get integrated
into the creative workflow and that is
where I think we would also look to
universities to help us understand how
these should get
integrated so like the uh emergence of
the calculator there was a lot of
anxiety about how this is going to
change the way we think about education
the calculator has the virtue that it
predictably gives you the correct answer
so there's uh there's a funny phenomenon
you mentioned which is you know AI
hallucination are
we and I think those of us in science
and engineering are are kind of
particularly uh unnerved by this so you
you ask generative AI a question that
has to do with a research topic and
sometimes it just gives you the wrong
answer so bsers yeah and it g sometimes
gives you that answer in a very
expert-like way exactly it sounds like
the right answer uh to what's your sort
of response to that in terms of what
you're seeing in the research front can
we amarate that can we think about it in
a way that makes it sort of seem like
more of a Bonafide research tool for
serious engineer yeah so I think there's
a lot of research going on in how you
deal with that and how you mitigate that
uh you know there are techniques like
rag retrieval augmented Generation Um
that reduce it to a large extent some of
the grounding things that say okay I
generated it but I got it from here so
it's kind of an accelerator you look at
the output you don't completely rely on
it but you can quickly check it right so
I think those are there and I think
there's a lot of research to be done
this I think is a really good area for
fundamental research um and especially I
think even to a large extent these
neural Nets are still not fully
understood how these are operating and I
think that's a great area for University
Research
so in terms of where you you mentioned
sort of great institutions like y of
course we're all big fans of yil but
where do you see our comparative
advantage in this space in terms of
preparing students to enter this kind of
new I mean really novel transformed work
Workforce I think there are a couple of
aspects one is um yeah
has Yale has some of the best research
and teaching
and and professors across a variety of
fields and a lot of this applying AI to
healthcare requires collaboration
between you know people who know
medicine deeply and people who know
computer science deeply and people who
know engineering deeply because you know
you have doing these sensors and so on
uh there's a lot of implications on
society and public policy you know
um one of the examples that I would love
to see and you know we would love to
collaborate on that is there are
customers who say you know I have all
kinds of legal contracts that I sign
with everyone can you quickly if I
upload three or four of these legal
contracts can you quickly tell me if
there are conflicting portions in there
right and so an interaction with you
know the law school and someone from the
computer science department would be
great you know public policy is right
for this so I think one of the things
that Yale can really do is that
interdisciplinary portion and then the
second part which I think a university
like Yale um can do that is probably
generally true of a lot of universities
but I think more true of Yale because
Yale has this really strong theoretical
foundations to everything that it has
done is really furthering the
understanding at a theoretical basic
level of what is going on with some of
these neural Nets and you know as you
are saying Dean BR I think there's a lot
of need to get into the system side
because when you get into the system
side you're truly impacting society and
shipping products but I think without
losing that core theoretical strength
because someone has to do that for us to
really truly understand these systems
yeah all right very good I think I've
exhausted my short list of questions but
I I know there must be many in the
audience if there anyone who okay your
first hand up in the front row here Here
Comes oh perfect hi my name is Neil SATA
I'm a an undergrad studying computer
science uh I actually I interned at AWS
this past summer in Santa Clara okay um
so good to meet you as as my boss yeah
um my question which I got asked by
family and friends for the past few
months was where is AWS in the
conversation of you know where is aws's
chat GPT so maybe you could discuss and
you mentioned in your road map earlier
uh just highlight some of aws's
strengths in that moving forward I think
our key strength is making
systems fit for Enterprise usage right
now I won't say it's easy but it's one
thing to get something out that a lot of
consumers can use but when you're
thinking of an about an Enterprise
setting you really have a very different
bar in terms of robustness in terms of
accuracy and so on and so forth right
and so now you're see I'll give you an
example think of code Whisperer that I
talked about you can and other companies
have come out with tools of here is how
you use generative AF for software we
came out with code Whisperer and a lot
of a time was spent in putting accurate
license attributions so what you do is
when you're generating code you have to
make sure it does not is not a copy
paste of somebody else's code and if
that's somebody else's code has a proper
license you got to be able to generate
code that has that copyright attribute
we were the first to come out with here
is software development and here is the
appropriate license for it right and if
you don't have that you can use that for
research projects or just fun hackathons
you cannot use that in Industry so our
core thing is how do you make these
appropriate and suitable for industry
and that I think is a core strength that
is the place we know it
that's great that applies to scientific
research as well where you need
appropriate citations across the space
Sorry next
question
than yes thank you bran for an amazing
talk um I'm Sam hyek I'm a fellow in one
of the Yale colleges
um 5 10 years from now um how Amazon
will need to differentiate its AI
products um to compete with you know
let's say the microsofts and the other
competitors um One Way obviously is to
make the products you know um user
friendly and so on and so forth I'm
concerned about the not for Amazon
itself but all the
players about the Integrity of the
fundamental uh uh data um could you give
us examples of how you
um how you ensure
Integrity um you very simply make sure
that let's say the image one of the
images that you're feeding into the ml
system is not uh corrupt and it's not
giving the the wrong results yeah I'm
glad you asked that question because
that's something that's top of mind for
us you know and Integrity security
privacy this is just foundational to
everything we do not just a ML and you
know we have whole teams that are
focused on that so we have a lot of
mechanisms for that one of the things
that pretty much every service does is
and we do in the in the AI Spaces end to
endend encryption of everything so you
have encryption at rest encryption in
transit with customer provided Keys okay
so there's just no way um anyone can do
um anyone can kind of access access that
data um there are a bunch of other
mechanisms we use in terms of ensuring
privacy of the data and uh you know we
will also be coming up with some
Innovations now that actually reuse or
reuse some of the latest signs in terms
of um how you do that so this is you
know this is pretty fundamental to
everything we're building uh one of the
other things I'll also mention that a
lot of customers are doing with
generative AI is they're saying look
I have I mean it could be a it could be
a company um I'll give you example so
for example we have a Pharma company
let's say that wants to use this uh
generative Ai and enable its chemists
and the way it wants to enable its
chemists is they want to be able to go
in and say hey give me all of the
experiments that this company has run in
the last 10 years about the side effects
of this drug and today you have to run a
lot of searches and now with you can
imagine with generative AI it can just
find it out but the issue is that that
data is not public okay only that
company has it and so you need to be
able to customize those models with your
own data right now the way we do it kind
of you know answers the previous
question is pretty unique the way we do
it is when you customize the model want
to customize the model we actually
create your own private copy of the
model and then we create it in your own
virtual private Cloud okay so it's in
your own security domain so we have a
lot of these mechanisms that we are
using to en ensure the security of the
data good y
next hi I'm Ben D I'm an international
student in here College I would like to
ask you which in Industries are least
likely to be affected by AI um in your
opinion because there is like a debate
on like which
occupations um which which Industries
which jobs are least likely to be
affected in your personal opinion in the
long term whichi develops you know this
I think is a fundamental Innovation that
ultimately will touch every aspect of
what we do right um and the way I look
at it is it'll it'll generate so much
new stuff net net technology has been at
least in my view netn Net Technology has
been uh a positive force for society as
a positive force for Humanity we have
become more productive you know we do a
lot more and I think this is yet another
of those transformational technologies
that will do the same and I suspect just
like the internet just like some of the
key technical Parts it's going to be
integrated into everything we
do you know ultimately we humans
create right ultimately we do some form
of creation and this I think will be an
assistant in
that uh Andrew uh office of development
you mentioned using AI to have uh help
with interactions between patients and
doctors I was wondering if you foresee
any unique roadblocks with medicine with
privacy concerns or you know Hippa
anything like that that may make it more
difficult to be
incorporated so you know the things that
I mentioned were all heppa compliant um
I think in
medicine you obviously have a much
higher bar because you know you don't
want it in in situations where the
errors could be in there so the bar
there will be higher and probably at
least initially it'll be a lot more of
an assistant functionality but there's
always a human in the loop that is doing
the checking of the verification so
let's say instead of a human creating
the whole thing that took them an hour
it'll probably be a human verifying the
output and doing edits as needed that
takes them 10 minutes so it's really
going to be a productivity enhancer
rather than a
replacer than hi I'm Michael Cohen I'm a
public citizen here and uh there was an
old expression in Computing garbage in
garbage out if you look at the data
that's out there there's a lot of
garbage out there how do you tell the
difference between like Newsmax and the
New York Times yeah um so there is a
huge you know there is and I didn't go
into that there is a lot of engineering
work we put in but there's a lot of
science as well and there's actually two
parts to this so when we train our
models we have an entire team that is
curating the data so that's curating the
data uh not just for the kind of content
but also for things like bias and
toxicity and so on so you don't want to
train the model within appropriate data
of all kinds right so that's one aspect
of it um and we have huge teams that are
working on that like you know lots of
people whose real job whose job solely
is to just not just collect the data but
verify it okay but I also think there's
a lot of research to be done now there's
a second aspect of that which is how do
you use the minimum amount of data to
get the desired outcome right so there
is a lot of work that shows that if you
had a better way of curating your data
you might be able to get to the same
result with fewer training Cycles so
there's work to be done there and I
think there's work to be done there's a
lot of research to be done in how do you
more efficiently curate these data
sources so today it's a pretty not a
pretty it's it's a very labor intensive
effort and that in many
situations is when we training these
large language models in many situations
that data collection and curation and
filtering effort is actually the larger
bottleneck that's another good role for
Discerning Yale undergraduates to play
in this um so we have time for one more
question sorry yes go
ahead hi my name is Ursula I'm also a
computer science student here I was
wondering if you had any um things that
were top of Mind relating to the
intersection um of cyber security and
generative Ai and is there something
that you think Amazon should be working
on that um they aren't pursuing at the
moment oh so you know I won't talk about
all our road map stuff and you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of work
we are doing that you know we bring out
um in the course of time I think
generative Ai and cyber
security um cyber security I think will
get a lot more interesting with
generative AI in two different ways one
is you know Bad actors can use
generative AI to create more of these
threats okay more um you know more
threats that compromise systems and so
there's that aspect where they now have
a new set of tools now there's the other
aspect of it which is you can use AI in
general and generative AI also to be
monitoring systems and to be raising the
barriers to uh people getting in so I
think there's both aspects of it and I
think there's work to be done including
a lot of very interesting research to be
done at the intersection of the two and
you know I suspect um I suspect there's
a lot of very interesting research to be
done
there okay great um so with that I'd
like to thank Our Guest fratton sah once
again for coming and uh I'd also like to
thank our team for helping us put this
together and SII City for hosting us uh
it's it's great to be able to run these
here so thanks very much once again
thank
[Music]
you